this video is brought to you by
brilliant welcome to another episode of
Cold Fusion it's the year 2054 and the
United States has just federally
launched a new police unit it's special
precisely because the police will arrest
people who commit crimes in the future a
concept known as pre- crime this is of
course the plot to the 2002 movie
Minority Report such a world where
crimes are known before they're
committed is disturbing it sits in
between the Comforts of security and low
crime but also complete government
knowledge and control it's scary but at
the end of the day it's just a concept
in a movie or is
it this next breakthrough is a lot
deeper all the way down to the very
tissue of our brains where researchers
have used AI to translate brain scans
into text UT researchers have
essentially created a device called a
semantic decoder that can read a
person's mind by converting brain
activity into a string of text next in
May of 2023 at the University of Texas
at Austin a device was created that can
turn a person's brain activity and
thoughts into a conscious understandable
stream of text the company meta also
recently did the same but that's not all
just last month meta also unveiled an AI
system that can analyze a person's brain
waves and predict what that person is
looking at if that's not enough they
were able to do this in real time
basically the system was mind reading
has a multi-billion dollar social media
conglomerate just created a telepathy
device with the help of generative AI on
the one hand this is a potential
disaster for privacy but on the other
hand such Technologies could help many
who can't speak due to illness or injury
it appears that these days every major
technological innovation raises more
questions than answers we're not quite
yet at the capabilities of Minority
Report but reading brain waves and
interpreting what people are thinking is
a step in that direction in this episode
we'll take a look at all of this so get
ready for a wild ride let's start by
diving deep into the university mind
reading AI then we'll get onto what meta
is doing you're going to want to hang
around for that one because it's world
changing
[Music]
stuff you are watching cold fusion
TV UT's newest artificial intelligence
tool could be a game changer D for some
folks our real hope uh is that this
could help people who have lost the
ability to communicate for some reason
Jerry Tang a doctoral student in
computer science and Alexander Huth an
assistant professor of Neuroscience and
computer science led the research at the
University of Texas at Austin the team
that developed the mind reading device
they published their study in the
Journal of Nature Neuroscience the mind
reading device is called a non-invasive
language decoder while language decoders
are not new using them with the recent
breakthroughs in generative AI certainly
is older versions could recognize only a
few words here or there or at best a
couple of phrases Jerry tang and his
team have managed to blow this out of
the water their device can reconstruct
continuous language from perceived
speech imagined speech and Silent videos
a technology like neuralink on the other
hand would be an invasive method it
would provide clearer data but has
higher risks
associated
the UT Austin team created a new system
called a semantic decoda it works by
analyzing non-invasive brain recordings
through functional magnetic resonance
imaging or
fmri the decoder reconstructs what a
person perceives or imagines into
continuous natural language it sounds
incredible but before we get too excited
let's understand the limitations of a
non-invasive system and the challenges
that the researchers had to overcome
while invasive methods such as
electrodes implanted into the brain have
demonstrated notable achievements in the
past non-invasive systems are still in
their early stages of development
trailing behind in vital areas the team
chose the non-invasive fmri because it
has excellent spatial specifity meaning
that it can pinpoint neuroactivity in
the brain with great accuracy however
its major limitation is its temporal
resolution or in other words how quickly
it captures changes in brain activity
the blood oxygen level dependent or bold
signal that the fmri measures is
notoriously slow taking about 10 seconds
to rise and fall in response to neural
activity now imagine trying to decode
natural language where we speak at a
rate of one to two words per second so
how did they tackle this problem to
address this researchers employed an
encoding model which predicts how the
brain responds to natural language to
train the model they recorded brain
responses while subjects listen to 16
hours of spoken narrative stories by
extracting the semantic features and
using linear regression they built an
accurate model of the brain's responses
to different word sequences it's uh
basically a model that has been trained
with over 15 hours of data per person to
take in their brain activity when
they're sitting in an MRI scanner and to
spit out the story that they're
listening to here is where it becomes a
little more interesting to ensure the
words that were decoded had proper
English grammar and structure the
research SE archers Incorporated a
generative neural network language model
or generative AI interestingly they used
gpt1 an earlier version of the now
famous chat GPT models this model can
accurately predict the most likely words
to follow in a given sequence but here's
the catch with countless possible word
sequences it would be impractical to
generate and score each one individually
this is where a clever algorithm called
beam search comes into play let me
briefly explain how this works first it
analyzes brain activity
and then generates word sequences one
word at a time it starts with a group of
the most probable word sentences as it
analyzes brain activity further and
identifies new words it generates more
possible continuations for each sequence
in the group this approach gradually
Narrows down possibilities and the most
promising options are kept for each step
by keeping the most credible sequences
the decoder continuously refines its
predictions and determines the most
likely words over time an example would
be necessary here consider the scenario
if a person hears or thinks the word
Apple the decoder learns the
corresponding brain activity when the
person encounters a new word or sentence
the algorithm utilizes learned
associations to generate a word sequence
matching the language stimulus's meaning
for example if a person hears or thinks
I ate an apple the algorithm May
generate I consumed a fruit or an apple
was in my mouth the generated word
sequence may not be an exact replica but
it captures the semantic representation
so with the help of an ingenious
encoding system generative Ai and a
clever search algorithm the scientists
were able to circumvent the limitations
of invasive fmri
[Music]
scans so with the challenges tackled it
was time for the researchers to put the
system to the test and see what it could
do the team trained decoders for three
individuals and evaluated each person's
decoder by analyzing the brain responses
while listening to to new stories the
goal was to determine if the decoder
could understand the meaning of the
information and the findings absolutely
remarkable the decoded word sequences
not only captured the meaning of the
information but often replicated the
exact words and phrases this shows that
semantic information or in-depth meaning
can indeed be extracted from brain
signals measured by
[Music]
fmri the researchers also wanted to find
out whether different parts of the brain
have similar or different information
about language essentially they were
looking for how the decoding process
works across cortical regions cortical
regions are specific areas in the outer
layer of the brain known as the cerebral
cortex each region corresponds to
distinct sensory motor or cognitive
processes the researchers compared
predictions from decoding word sequences
in these regions and they discovered
something extraordinary they found out
that diverse brain regions redundant ly
encode Word level language
representations basically our brains
have backup systems for language
understanding and usage it's like having
several copies of the same book if you
lose one copy or it gets damaged you can
still read the book with another copy so
it suggests that even if one brain
region is damaged others can process the
same information preserving our language
abilities and that's a pretty
astonishing
[Music]
find the researchers went even further
they tested their system on imagine
speech which is crucial for interpreting
silent speech in the brain participants
were told to imagine stories during fmri
scans and the decoder successfully
identified the content and meaning of
their stories the researchers were
ecstatic about their new discoveries and
intrigued by the prospect of decoding
other types of information as well so
they explored cross modal decoding
researchers say they were surprised the
decoders still worked even when the
participants weren't hearing spoken
language even when somebody is seeing a
movie you can kind of the model can kind
of predict uh word descriptions of what
they're seeing this study is a
significant advancement for brain
computer interfaces that don't require
invasive methods however the study
highlighted the need to include motor
features and participant feedback to
improve the decoding process but this
story isn't over as promised meta has
come into the picture and they've come
to raise the bar of what we thought was
possible although in the movie Minority
Report it was psychics that helped
reveal the intentions of an individual
it's AI That's looking to do the same
here in real life but how does AI work
anyway well now there's a fun and easy
way to learn about that and many other
stem subjects with today's sponsor
brilliant brilliant's course on
artificial neural networks is perfect
for that I've used it to brush up on
some background context when I was
making AI episodes brilliant has
interactive stem courses in anything
from maths and computer science to
General Science and statistics whether
you just want to brush up on learning or
need a refresher for your career
brilliant has you covered you can get
started free for 30 days and the first
200 people to sign up get 20% off an
annual plan visit the URL brilliant.org
coldfusion to get started thanks and now
back to the
episode on October 18th 2023 meta pushed
this field of research even further
instead of using fmri which has a
resolution range of one data point every
few seconds meta used meeg technology
another non-invasive neuroimaging
technique which can take thousands of
brain activity measurements per second
with this they created an AI system
capable of decoding visual
representations in the brain the system
can be deployed in real time to
reconstruct from brain activity the
images perceived and processed by the
brain at each instant I told you this
was going to get wild
the system consists of three parts an
image encoder a brain encoder and an
image decoder the AI was trained on a
public data set of Meg recordings
acquired from healthy Volunteers in
meta's research it was found that quote
brain signals best align with modern
computer vision AI systems like Dino
V2 this AI learned imagery by itself and
wasn't supervised by human labels meta
states that quote self-supervised
learning leads AI systems to learn learn
brain-like representations the
artificial neurons in the algorithm tend
to be activated similarly to physical
neurons in the human brain in response
to the same image this functional
alignment between such AI systems and
the Brain can be used to guide the
generation of images similar to what the
participants see in the scanner using
this technique meta managed to read the
minds of people and interpret what they
were looking at on the left is the
original image shown to the participant
on the right is what the AI thinks the
person is looking at and remember this
resulting image was only determined by
the brain waves the AI had no idea what
the person was actually looking at the
resulting images could nail broad object
categories but were unstable in the
finer
details meta claims that their research
is ultimately to guide the development
of AI systems designed to learn and
reason like humans we'll see about
that envisioning the future of brain
reading technology is challenging but
the potential could be V last for
instance it could help those who are
mentally conscious but are unable to
speak or communicate thinking further a
field imagine if a smartphone's volume
notifications and music selection would
adapt to a user's mood or brain activity
and smartphones and other devices could
be commanded or queried just by thoughts
alone it would be like speaking to
Google Assistant but with your brain
next sense which originated from
Google's parent company alphabet's X
division has been working on something
interesting since 2020 the startup is
currently developing earbuds with the
remarkable ability to capture human
brain signals these earbuds have the
potential to Monitor and diagnose brain
conditions like epilepsy depression and
Sleep Disorders they can also detect
seizures assess medication Effectiveness
improve deep sleep and provide valuable
insights for comprehensive brain
assessment now there's obviously a long
way to go with brain scanning technology
but it's clear that we're at the very
start of a new era of interpreting the
human brain thanks to generative AI on
the negative side however the sum of all
of this technology could be a privacy
catastrophe imagine meta or Google being
able to know what you're looking at or
what you're even thinking in order to
better Target their advertising or to
sway public opinion in one way or the
other who knows what this technology
will evolve into in the next 30 Years in
the very same era that Minority Report
is set in with meta getting involved
there are natural concerns for me mind
decoding technology in research is one
thing but having popular wearable
technology such as the meta VI headset
or video camera glasses could be a
future Temptation for the firm meta were
never known for their care of user
privacy and consent though still to
achieve true mind reading or telepathy
the decoding technology would need to
overcome a lot of challenges and
limitations accuracy and resolution must
increase the system would need to
understand tone emotion and contextual
nuances of thoughts second it would
would need to work in both directions
allowing a person to both send and
receive thoughts from one person to
another so true telepathy remains firmly
rooted in fiction and perhaps that's for
the best so back to the university
researchers for a
second the scientific world has been
stunned the findings of the semantic
Dakota are undeniably remarkable tonight
we turn to news in one specific way that
artificial intelligence technology is
changing our world and it is absolutely
remarkable these neuroscientists at the
University of Texas in Austin say
they've made a major breakthrough they
figured out how to translate brain
activity into words using artificial
intelligence Dr Alexander Huth the lead
researcher expressed his surprise to the
guardian saying quote we were kind of
shocked that it works as well as it does
I've been working on this for 15 years
so it was shocking and exciting when it
finally did work end quote the
Breakthrough captured widespread
attention from the media and scientists
alike Professor Tim Beren from the
University of Oxford praised the study's
technical press highlighting its
potential to decipher thoughts and
dreams and reveal new ideas from
subconscious brain activity he said to
the guardian quote these generative
models are letting you see what's in the
brain at a new level it means that you
can really read out something deep from
the fmri end quote when you stop and
think about it an artificial brain
interpreting the internal happenings of
a human brain makes total sense but it's
just something that I thought would be a
long way off it's just my opinion but I
think that these AI Technologies truly
shine when they're applied to scientific
research and studies like this that's
when we get to harness the full power of
artificial
intelligence so there you have it brain
decoders that utilize the power of AI to
interpret human thoughts and generate
coherent language and imagery well at
least in a controlled environment for
now the scanners are still bulky and
expensive and the training process is
long and tiresome however as with all
technology this is only going to get
better of course there are concerns
companies could misuse this for their
own selfish gains but for the physically
impaired the possibilities are almost
endless personally I found this quite
fascinating but what are your thoughts
on this how do you guys think that this
is going to shape the future do you
think that it's good or bad to be able
to read or at least interpret someone's
thoughts or do you just think that this
technology should just never see the
light of day it's an interesting
discussion so feel free to discuss in
the comment section below all right so
that's about it from me thanks for
watching if you want to see anything
else on science technology business or
history feel free to subscribe to Cold
Fusion it's free my name is toogo and
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys have a good
[Music]
one
cold fusion it's new
thinking